The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TOMER ULLMAN: So yeah,
I'm going to spend
the rest of the tutorial
talking about Amazon Mechanical
Turk, although some of the stuff
just applies to, in general,
sort of making large scale
experiments on people
and crowds and things like that.
There are other alternatives.
I think Google has
some in-house things.
There's like crowd
flower or crowd
clicker or things like that.
But most of the
psychologists I know
that are doing stuff online
and large scale things
use Amazon Mechanical Turk.
So I'll be talking about that.
This is a crowdsourcing
platform which
is designed to do all
sorts of small tasks,
not necessarily psychophysics.
It was invented in around
or built in around 2005.
And the signature
tagline for it is
"Artificial artificial
intelligence."
So these are all sorts
of tasks that you
wish computers could do.
You don't want to
put people through it
but computers can't do it yet.
So let's have people
do it for now.
Amazon sort of invented
it for in-house purposes
to get rid of duplicate pages.
They really wanted
an algorithm to do
that for duplicate postings,
but there really wasn't one.
So they just paid some
people very little money
to do a lot of these pages.
And then they figured, wait
a minute, a lot of companies
probably want this
sort of service
so they offered it to
the general public.
Do people know what
the original turk was,
the original Mechanical Turk?
Who doesn't know,
raise their hands.
OK, so Mechanical Turk, the name
comes from this 18th century
mechanical contraption
called the turk,
which was a chess playing
device that supposedly ran
on clockwork and could beat some
of the finest minds in Europe.
I think at some point it played
like the Austrian duchess
or whatever it was the empress
and Napoleon and things
like that.
And it floored people,
how could this work?
And you know, the
inventor said, well,
I've invented a thinking device.
And the clockwork
just solves it.
And a lot of people of course
figured that it must be a hoax
but they couldn't be sure
exactly how it worked.
And it was, of course, a hoax.
All of these gears and
boxes and clockwork
is just designed to
distract you from the fact
that you could fit
a person inside.
I mean, people have
thought of that, obviously,
but it was cleverly designed
so that you couldn't quite
find it.
And nobody knows for sure
because the original work was
destroyed before people put
forward the exact hypothesis,
but the consensus
now is that it must
have been just some person
inside making the moves.
At some point people
have suggested
it must have been a well-trained
child or a small person
or something like that
because the compartment must
be really small.
That's not thinking right now.
It was just some more magic, but
not magic in the Harry Potter
sense magic, in the
stage magic sense.
So, what sorts of
tasks do people
run on Amazon Mechanical Turk?
Well actually, the
majority is not
psychophysics or psychologists.
There are a lot of companies
using Amazon Mechanical
Turk to do things like, hey,
garner positive reviews for us.
Go to this website and
write something nice
about our product.
Or you know, translate
some text for me instead
of hiring some
professional to do it,
most people who-- there's a lot
of people on Amazon Mechanical
Turk that can probably
translate something for you
from English to Spanish and
back, English to Chinese
and back, things like that.
And they can do it
for much less money
than you would need to pay
a professional translator.
Another thing that may be more
up your alley is, you know,
you've heard a lot about
supervised training and things
like that, and big
data sets that are
used to train things like
convolutional neural networks.
The supervised part usually
comes from somewhere.
Somebody has to
tag those images.
Somebody has to go
over a million images
and say dog, not dog, dog, not
dog, not dog, two dogs, one
dog.
You want somebody to
go ahead and do that.
And you don't have
artificial intelligence
to do it for you, yet.
I mean, CNN's are getting
better but someone
had to tag it for them.
And that's the sort of
thing that you would
use Amazon Mechanical Turk for.
Look at this image.
Tell me, is there a social
interaction or isn't there?
Now do that for the
next 100 images.
Let's get 1,000
people to do that.
You get the sense of like why
you would want to crowdsource
this kind of problem.
But there's also, you know,
just psychology, psychophysics,
the sort of thing that
you would bring people
into the lab to do but you don't
want to do for various reasons.
So the idea is you could collect
a lot of people responding
to stuff on the screen right,
exactly the sort of thing
that you would bring them into
the lab and measure something
that they're doing to a screen.
You could just have them doing
that to the screen at home,
or wherever the hell it is
that they're doing this thing.
So let's see, you could
do things like perception.
You know, just look at this.
Is it a dog?
Yes or no.
Or rather things
like the Stroop task.
If nobody had invented
the Stroop task,
you could do that on Amazon
Mechanical Turk and get famous.
I was going to say rich and
famous, but just famous.
You could do various
attention tasks.
You could do things like
learning and categorization
and bias.
Learning things like, here's
a tufa, here's a tufa,
here's a tufa.
Is this a tufa?
I mean, it's very easy
to do that on a screen.
You can do that on
Amazon Mechanical Turk.
You could do things
like implicit bias.
A lot of social
psychologists are
interested in that
sort of thing.
Let's see, what else.
You could do things like
morality, the trolley problem.
decision making, and economics,
and prisoner dilemmas,
and making predictions,
and tell us which one of these
two movies based on trailers
do you think will
win the best actor
award and things like that.
How would you actually run
something on Amazon Mechanical
Turk?
The first thing you would do
is register as a requester.
You would go to
requester.amazon.--
I'll send you the slides.
You can just click on that link
and it'll take you to the page
to register as a requester.
You would then you
do one of two things.
You could either do
the vanilla version
which is to just use
the Amazon template.
Amazon has made it
very simple for you
as a requester to bring up a
new experiment and just say,
I want to ask a simple
set of questions.
Now go.
And there are some parameters
that you need to set
and I'll show you those
in a second, what they do.
And if you're only interested
in very simple things,
like fill out this
box or click on one
of these two images or something
like that, that's perfect
and it's fine.
And Amazon takes care of
a lot of things for you
like saving the data.
You don't have to mess around
with like SQL databases
and things like
that on your own.
The other thing
that you could do
is to point people to
an external website.
Then you would have
to host it somehow.
The advantage there
is that then you
could do any sort of
fanciness that you want.
You could show them
custom animations,
have them play a game, record
how they're playing that game,
send them new things based on
how they're playing that game.
Or you could do
things like, you wait
until you record two people.
You record two people.
If you just recruit
one person, it just
says waiting, waiting, waiting.
Now you wait for
the next person.
Now you have them pitted
against one another
in some sort of game.
This has become more
popular in economics.
That's not the sort
of thing you could
do with the Amazon template.
But if you're good
at coding or you
can hire someone that's
reasonable at coding,
you can do that by pointing
them to an external website.
And we can show some
examples of that.
Then once you decide-- you
register as a requester.
You decide which one of
these things you want.
You build your website, either
you build the external website
or you just use the
Amazon template.
And then you test
it on a sandbox.
Don't run your experiments
live immediately.
I'll be giving sort of
tips throughout the thing.
This might be redundant for
some of you but not redundant
for others.
So there's a sandbox
where you can just
run it and get sort
of false responses
that don't count exactly where
people can sort of fill it in.
You might want to used
that before you go live
with 1,000 people
and say, oh god,
I miscoded that variable
and nothing is working.
So test it ahead of time.
And then, once you're
finally, finally done,
you would submit it.
You would just click, you
know, submit this thing.
You would pay the
money to Amazon.
And you also want to announce
it on several Mechanical Turk
forums, which I'll
get to in the end.
These are very helpful people.
They're very nice to you
if you're nice to them.
And it gets you a lot
more results very fast.
OK, let's see.
Why don't I show
you an example--
let me show you an example of
what a requester page looks
like, just to get a sense of it
for those of you who have not
seen this sort of thing before.
You can see our experiment
is almost finished.
I asked for 100 people on that.
So let's go to
something like create.
So this is what the
requester page looks like.
Here's all sorts
of projects that I
run on Amazon Mechanical Turk.
And you would do
something like new
or you would copy
something from something
old that you already did.
Let's just edit
that and show you
some examples of
what you can do.
You give a name,
you know, a title
for your own internal
title, like AI estimate.
You then give a title that
Amazon Mechanical Turkers see,
something like artificial
intelligence estimate,
short psychology study.
There, you probably want
to give a time estimate.
Turkers would prefer it if
you give them a time estimate.
They care about their time.
They care about their money.
They do like doing psychology.
They don't like filling
in endless bubbles,
you know, the standard
psychology things
where you rate 100 things like,
I feel this way or that way.
Don't do that.
But the sort of fun psychology
they're actually on board with.
It's much more fun than
writing show reviews.
You might want to give it a nice
title that will entice them,
an honest description,
like you know,
you'll answer a few
simple questions
on you'll watch a movie and
then answer two questions
or things like that.
Key words like easy, fun,
something descriptive
about the task, like AI, short.
Again, this is sort
of luring, and it's
good to do that if
you're honest about it.
Some people do things
like easy, fun,
100 pages of filling in
bubbles and things like that.
Don't do that.
They publish it in the
forums, like, this is a lie.
Don't do that.
This is where you say how much
you want to pay per assignment
and we'll get to how much you
should pay per assignment.
You'll notice it's very little.
You're paying these
people very little.
How much assignments
you want per hit.
Hit is just the
name for your task.
How much time you are
allotting them per assignment.
So someone has
accepted your hit, now
how long do they
have to carry it out.
You might think,
oh, my task only
takes two to three minutes,
so only give people
two to three minutes.
I don't want them
like taking the hit
and then going and
drinking some coffee
and then coming back to
it or something like that.
Consider still giving them
a whole bunch of time,
because a lot of the time,
you'll find that people if they
see that there's only a
five minute mark on it,
and if they don't
completed in five minutes
they're sort of concerned,
like, what is this thing?
And if I won't get done through
it in five minutes, you know,
I'll get disqualified
or something like that.
Give them some time.
Give them more than the ample
time to finish this thing.
You can, yourself,
keep around some timer
within the external website
or something like that,
or they actually actively
participating right now.
How long will this
hit stay up for?
And auto approve,
and things like that.
I'll talk a little bit
about rewards and incentives
and things like that.
Obviously, they care a lot
about things like money.
They care a lot about
things like how much you're
going to pay them.
They care about doing
it quickly so that they
can move on and get more money.
They care about it
being somewhat fun,
but that's not such
a big deal for them.
And they care about getting
it approved quickly.
OK, so you as a
requester, you will
get reviewed on various
forums and things like that.
If you get bad reviews, people
don't want to do your things.
One of the things that people
care a lot about is something
like getting approved quickly.
And quickly can be in a day
or two, something like that.
They don't want to have to wait
two weeks for that $0.50 that
you were supposed to give them.
You can do that if you want to.
You have the power
as the requester.
But if you want to
incentivize people,
try to make sure that
you approve them quickly
and let them know that you're
going to approve them quickly.
So that was just a
very general statement.
So who are the
sort of people that
are on Amazon Mechanical Turk?
Have people read these sort of
papers and things like that?
Do you know more or less?
Some of you do.
Some of you don't.
The use in India
make up about 80%--
by the way, this is in flux.
Like a study came out two years
ago about this sort of thing.
It's changed since then.
But the study two years ago, the
US and India make up about 80%,
with the US taking up
50-something percent, India
taking up the rest.
There are slightly more females
than males on Amazon Mechanical
Turk, and at least
the US population
is biased towards young and
educated people, educated
meaning a bachelor's degree.
It's certainly
more representative
of the general population
than just hiring,
you know, college students
during their bachelor's degree.
But it is still skewed,
keep that in mind.
It's skewed towards, basically,
the sort of population
that you would expect to find
on the internet in the United
States.
OK, so somewhat younger
people, somewhat more educated.
In general, you might
want to look at something
like Mason and
Siddharth were looking
at these sort of things.
I can send you the links later.
I was talking a little
bit about payments.
There's been a whole
load of studies
looking at querying the
Amazon Mechanical Turk pool.
Who are you?
What's your education?
Why are you doing this?
And then they ask why are you
doing this in various ways.
Are you doing it for fun?
Are you doing it to kill time?
Are you doing this as
a supplementary thing?
They're in it for money.
It's very obvious that
they're in it for money.
That's OK.
And keep that in mind
when you post hits.
You have a lot of
power as a requester.
You have a ton of power.
You have a ton of power to
dictate the terms of what
you're going to pay them.
You have a ton of power
to reject their work.
Once they basically do the hit
for you, you can then go back
and say, you failed
this question
or you didn't quite
get what we wanted,
or you actually did the
study two months ago
but I didn't implement checks
for that, I just asked you,
did you take the study before
and they didn't remember.
Something like that.
And then you reject their work.
And if you reject it too many
times, then they get banned.
First of all, if you
reject, they don't get paid.
If you reject it too many
times, they get banned.
These are people that are doing
it either as supplementary
or as their main income.
I don't know-- this may
seem obvious to some of you.
If this doesn't seem obvious
to at least one of you,
then I'll count it as
worthwhile to stress this.
You don't care about the $0.20.
These people do care
about the $0.20.
And again, it's not
because they're necessarily
from poor economical
backgrounds,
but they're in it for
the money and that's
what they're doing this for.
Try to give them fair pay.
And we'll stress that
again and tell you
what I mean by fair pay.
Try not to reject them.
OK, except in
extreme situations.
Even if they failed.
Even if they didn't do
your catch question.
Even if you think that they
just zoomed through this
or something like that,
that's usually on you
to catch that, as a
psychology researcher.
You're not a company.
You're a psychology researcher.
Try not to reject people.
Make sure you have some
ways set up ahead of time,
and I'll get to that,
to know who to reject.
But don't actually reject
people except in really extreme
situations.
Something about payments is
that Amazon takes up about 10.
They actually raise this to
20% to 40% of the payments.
And this is what I
was going to say.
There have been some attempts
within the psychologists that
has been doing Amazon
Mechanical Turk studies,
and this has also been fueled
by the community of Amazon
Mechanical Turkers, or
Turkers, to establish some sort
of guidelines for minimum pay.
So if people come
into the lab, there
are some guidelines on what
you're supposed to pay them.
There are no exact guidelines.
There's no enforcing
guidelines, at least not--
maybe there are within
particular universities
but there's no cross
university one guideline
to tell you you have to
pay people this much.
And that might be
tempting to say,
oh, I'll just pay
people, you know,
the minimum I can get away with.
I mean, if I can pay people
$0.05 to do a 10 minute task,
I'll do that.
Fine, I can get the
20 subjects I need.
It's a free market.
We're not trying to live here in
some sort of capitalist fantasy
of some sort.
I'm not going to get into
economics too much because I
think you guys know that
better than I do you don't need
my lecturing in that sense.
But a lot of people who have
looked into the ethics of this
recommend that you try
to estimate ahead of time
through a pilot how long
is this test going to take.
Based on that, pay them such
that it matches minimum wage.
Minimum wage being
somewhat flux, like,
you know, I forget if
it's like $10 an hour
or something like that.
It's probably less than that.
But something like that.
I'm not going to
tell you exactly how
much you should pay them.
But try to figure out more or
less minimum wage, more or less
how long your task takes and
pay them according to that.
Some general advantages
of Mechanical Turk,
in case you guys have not been
persuaded yet, let me say.
You can run large
scale experiments.
I started running
this experiment
on 100 people that would
have taken me a long time.
It's a silly experiment
as Nori pointed out.
It's not even exactly
an experiment.
But I wanted to check
how people's responses
compared to people in CBMM.
First of all, I wouldn't
do that in the lab.
So there's that.
But even if I were to do it in
a lab, getting 100 participants
would take a long, long time.
And for your more
serious experiments,
getting 100 participants
would take a long, long time.
Each one has to come in and
you have to talk to them.
And you have to explain to
them exactly what's going on.
And you usually can't
run them in parallel,
or at least you can run
only one or two in parallel.
Here we run 100
subjects in an hour.
And that's still amazing.
That's still flooring me.
And we can do it, so we
can do it very quickly.
A lot of people very quickly.
And what you can do with
large scale experiments
is usually test some very fine
grain things of your model.
If your model has
some things like,
well, I need to show people
all of these different things
and make all of these
different predictions.
And I just need 300
people to do that.
Or for example, what my dad
was presenting yesterday,
these minimal images.
Did he mention how
many people they
had to recruit on
Amazon Mechanical Turk
to do those minimal images?
Yes?
It's like it's thousands.
I think it's over 10,000 at this
point, or something like that.
And the reason is
because once you've
seen that thing, once you've
seen the minimal image,
you already know what it is.
You're biased.
You know it's a horse even
though a naive participant
wouldn't know it's a horse.
So you want to make sure
that you want 10,000
participants for this thing.
You're not going to get 10,000
participants in the lab.
No way.
So another thing
is that, as I said,
even if you're paying
people minimum wage
and things like that,
it's still pretty cheap
to get 100 subjects.
It's cheapish.
The ish is because you should
pay people some minimum wage.
It's replicable, ish.
What I mean here by replicable
is not what you might think,
which I'll get to
in another slide.
It's just if you want to hand
it off to another person.
Someone says, I don't quite
understand your protocol,
or I don't quite believe it, or
I want to tweak it in some way.
It's much harder, usually,
with lab protocols and things
like that.
We certainly know that
in baby experiments.
Wouldn't it be nice if we
could just port, you know,
I won't say who because
it doesn't really matter,
but some experiments of people.
They describe their
methods in the paper.
It's not really that great.
Wouldn't it be great
if we could just
copy paste their experiment
and run it with some tweaking.
With this sort of
thing, you can.
I mean, you need to be somewhat
on good terms with the person
you're asking for, but they can
just tell you, oh yeah, sure.
Here's the code for my website.
Just run it again.
Run it with your tweaks
and things like that.
There's an ish there and
I'll get to it in a second.
The participant pool, as
I said, it's more diverse.
So I was I was harping
before about this point
that the pool doesn't quite
represent the US in general,
it's more like the US
population on the internet.
That's still a lot more
diverse than recruiting
college students.
It's a lot more diverse, let's
see, I have here in response
to gender, socioeconomic status,
geographic region, and age.
On all these things
that people have
tested on Amazon
Mechanical Turk,
the sample is a
lot more diverse,
is a lot more representative
of the general population,
is a lot less weird.
Weird being like Western,
educated, industrialized, rich,
democracies, which is
usually the pool that's
been studied in psychology.
These pools are a
lot more diverse.
They're not diverse
enough for certain things
in social psychology, and that's
this paper by Weinberg, where
he says, you know, sometimes
social psychologists really,
really, really want to
control for making sure
that age is not a factor,
or something like that.
Or they really want to get
it what the population is,
or age they think plays a
factor, or something like that.
So you need a population
where they call it
sort of like knowledge experts.
You build some pool.
You build some
pool that you say,
OK, the reason
this pool exists is
because it's representative
of the population.
And now we're going
to go to this pool
and just try them again
and again and again
on many different experiments.
It's sort of like
your, you know,
not exactly private but shared
between some universities
pool of social
psychology participants.
They've tested that
and they've shown
that mechanical
turkers are better
than those pools in terms
of things like attention,
filling out the
correct responses,
and things like that.
So yay Mechanical Turk.
But there are some things like
implicit biases and things
that social
psychologists care about,
where you don't know if the
effect is something like age,
or something like that.
I don't know if this
matters to a lot of you
but it's important to keep in
mind for those of you who do.
Here's this point about
will it replicate.
You know, some people
who are being introduced
to Amazon Mechanical Turk,
or thinking about it, usually
say, yeah, that's fine.
But how do I know that
people are actually doing
what will happen in the lab?
I might do it on
Mechanical Turk,
but then if I do
it in the lab, it
won't replicate or
things like that.
So people have tried a
bunch of the psychophysics
that Leyla was talking
about before, and more.
They tried stroop, switching,
Flanker, Simon, Posner, cueing,
intentional, blink, subliminal
priming, and category learning.
And they've done
a whole lot more.
This is just from one
study by Crump et al.,
where one of the et al.
is Todd Gureckis, who
we'll get to in a second.
And what they find was
basically replication
on all of these classic
psychology stuff, the sort
of effects you would expect.
The sort of effect
sizes you would expect.
The only thing that
was a bit different
was in category learning where
you show people something
like, this is a tufa.
This is a tufa.
Is this a tufa?
Where there are different
types of learning,
type one being easier, type
two being of a little harder,
type three being much harder.
Where the classic finding was
something like a graded thing.
And for Amazon Mechanical
Turk, it was more--
it was really hard for
them beyond type one.
Now is that a failure
of replication
or is that because
the original study was
done on college students
who are young and educated?
And this is actually
more representative
of the population, but
this is harder to learn.
I'm not quite sure.
The takeaway here is that, yeah,
it seems like, in general, it
will replicate,
at least certainly
for simple perceptual stuff.
Concerns of running things
on Amazon Mechanical Turk.
And I can send a whole
bunch of recent papers
that are very nice about it.
One of them was
specifically-- there's
been a bunch of like
New York Times papers
on Amazon Mechanical
Turk in general.
There's been a very recent
one a few months ago
on using it for psychophysics
experiments in particular.
It's called the Internet's
Hidden Science Factory.
It's a very nice
paper to check out.
And they make all these points
about the sort of things
that you probably thought
about as a researcher
but it bears
thinking about again,
which is, people
don't necessarily
pay that much
attention to your task.
You have no control.
They're not in the lab.
They give some quotes
there, which is, you know,
Nancy's employees don't know--
yeah, I think it's Nancy.
I changed the name.
Nancy's employers
don't know that Nancy
works while negotiating
her toddlers milk bottles
and giving him hugs.
They don't know that
she's seen studies
similar to theirs, maybe
hundreds, possibly thousands
of times.
So that brings us,
actually, to another thing,
which is repeated exposure.
This is a big concern.
By the way, sorry, I'm going
sort of back and forth here
because before I
leave attention,
I want to mention
just one thing, which
is attention is a problem you
want to put in attention cues.
And I'll talk about how
to do that in a second.
But we've had this a lot
with people in the lab.
I'm sure that some of you
have experienced this as well.
You put them in a room because
they need to have privacy
while they're doing the task,
you go in to check on them
and they're on their phone.
This happens a lot.
So attention is something that
you want to check in the lab
as well.
A lot of these concerns are
not just about Mechanical Turk,
but it's certainly easier
for people in Mechanical Turk
to not quite pay attention.
Repeated exposure
is a huge problem.
And it's a problem for
two different reasons.
One is that it
destroys intuition.
I was asking about the trolley
problem and you all went,
oh, the trolley problem.
People on Turk are doing
that even more than you are.
They see the trolley
problem, they've seen it.
I guarantee you,
it's very difficult
to find a Turker that has
not seen the trolley problem.
They've seen it.
They've seen it 1,000 times.
They've seen all the variations.
And they complain about it.
And they're satiated.
And they're sick of it.
They will say things like, if
I see one more trolley problem,
just kill them all.
Is there a way to kill the
five and the other person
on the other side of the track?
I don't care anymore.
OK, they're completely satiated.
It's kind of like saying,
hammer, hammer, hammer, hammer.
It loses all meaning
at some point.
You don't have the gut
intuitive response.
And even if they're
doing their best,
even if they're not
trying to fool you,
even if they're honestly trying
to answer, they just can't.
They don't have the
gut intuitive response
anymore for the stuff
that you're asking them.
Some ways to get around that
is to try even simple changes.
Just don't call it the
trolley problem anymore.
Set up something
else, which is not
5 versus 1, which is 10 versus
2 and it involves pineapples.
Like something.
You know, these small
changes can matter a lot.
So that's one thing
about repeated exposure,
that it destroys intuition
and related to that,
there's something
called super Turkers.
These are people that,
you know, 1% of Turkers
is responsible for about
10% to 15% of all studies.
So when I say people
have seen it a lot,
that's part of the reason.
There's a lot of people doing--
the same small group
of people is probably
responsible for a
lot of these studies.
The other reason that repeated
exposure ruined things for us
is because, you know, it just
ruins basic correlations.
So let me let me
give you an example.
Who here has heard of the
ball and bat question?
Who here has not heard of
the ball and bat question?
OK, let me pose it to you.
Those of you who suddenly
say, oh yeah, I know this.
Sh.
I'm interested in people who
have not heard this before.
So it's a simple question.
A ball and a bat
together cost $1.10.
The bat costs $1
more than the ball.
How much does the ball cost?
I'll explain that again.
A bat and a ball
costs $1.10 together.
The bat costs dollar
more than the ball.
How much does the ball cost?
Anyone?
Shout it out.
AUDIENCE: $0.05.
TOMER ULLMAN: Yeah, $0.05.
Who would have said
$0.10, don't be shy.
Thank you.
Thank you for
being brave enough.
A lot of people say $0.10.
They say immediately.
The ball costs $0.10.
The bat costs $1.
Wait, but it costs $1.
No, no, it costs $1 more.
So it's-- does everyone get
why $0.10 is not the answer,
it should be $0.05?
OK, good.
This was sort of
a classic question
along with two other questions
called the lily pad question
and the widget question.
The widget question is something
like five widget machines
make five widgets
in five minutes.
How long does it take 100 widget
machines to make 100 widgets?
Five minutes, right.
Not 100.
These sort of three
questions were found out
to correlate a lot better
with things like IQ tests
or even better, sorry, than IQ
on a lot of different things.
They've been found, you
know, many smart people
from MIT and Harvard included
have failed this question.
And the point was,
you know, people
have made a big deal about it.
Like this is even better than IQ
tests on all sorts of measures.
And it's so simple.
We don't have to run
100 IQ test questions.
Let's just ask the
ball and bat question
and then see what
that correlates with.
And it also relates
to, you know,
Kahneman makes a
big deal about it.
It's system one
versus system two.
System one really wants to
answer that it costs $0.10.
And you could solve it.
Of course you
could all solve it.
It's not hard for you if you
wrote down the simple equation,
it's trivial.
Right, you wrote
it down as like x.
And x costs this.
And you could all solve this.
You could all solve
this in middle school.
But you don't.
Like system to-- some of you do.
But usually the first time
you hear it, you don't.
And you don't-- even
if people are warned,
like this is a bit of a
trick question, you know,
think about it,
they don't, usually.
And people have used this as
like ways to test system one--
do people know what
I mean when I say
system one versus system two?
Who doesn't?
Raise your hand.
So very, very quickly
because it's not
that relevant to Mechanical
Turk, but very, very quickly,
you should read Thinking
Fast and Slow by Kahneman.
The point is that the
mind can generally
be categorized into two systems,
even Kahneman doesn't quite
believe that, but it's
sort of this thing that's
easy to talk about.
System one is the fast,
heuristic system that gives you
the cache response system.
Two is the slow, laborious,
can't do many things
at one time system.
That's the sort of
thing that you would
use to solve algebra problems.
That's the reason you need to
slow down when you're thinking
about something very hard.
System one is the
sort of thing that
gives you biases and heuristics
and things like that.
This was given as an
example of the bat and ball
was like one of the prime
examples of system one
wants to do this, system
two wants to do that.
System two is lazy,
doesn't actually
get engaged unless it
really, really has to.
Why am I bring this up?
The reason I bring this
up is because people
thought it was a great idea
to put it on Amazon Mechanical
Turk and ask people
a lot of questions
to see what it correlates with.
Everybody knows about
the ball and bat problem
on Amazon Mechanical Turk.
Everybody.
Don't think that
you're being unique.
Don't ask them the
widget problem.
lily pad problem.
They all know about it.
And here it's not a
problem for intuitive,
you know, being satiated
and things like that.
Even if they want to,
right, I said before,
like they want to tell you what
the thing is, they just don't
have the gut response anymore.
Here they just know it.
The reason most of you
answered, or those of you
who knew about it
said, haha, $0.05.
I know that one.
I've solved it before.
People on Mechanical
Turk know that too.
And it's sort of destroyed
any sort of measure
it had for whatever the heck
it was trying to measure.
In general, there's sort
of this growing sense
that since 2010,
people have been
trying to make Amazon
Mechanical Turk more
popular for a few years.
It feels almost like an
overexploited resource,
a little bit.
Like you have this tribe which
doesn't know about numbers.
Let's all go and study them and
ask them a billion questions.
And the reason they
don't know about numbers
is because they
don't know English.
And by the time we are done with
them, they will know English.
And the one thing
they'll know in English
is how to count to
10 because we've
asked them all these questions.
Amazon Mechanical Turk
feels a little bit
like this over exploited
resource at sometimes.
These have been more
concerns for you
as a requester working on
Amazon Mechanical Turk, things
to sort of keep in
mind and watch out for.
Here are some concerns for
people on Mechanical Turk
that you can try to alleviate.
And these sort of things about--
I've already mentioned sort
of two of them about low pay
and rejecting people for no good
reason and things like that.
One more thing I
want to point out
is this thing about
no de-briefing.
When people coming
to the lab, you
can tell them why they
were in the study.
That's a basic part of the
protocol of psychology.
When people are on
Amazon Mechanical Turk,
it's a good thing to put
it in the experiment,
why were you in this experiment
if you have such a thing,
and you're running
an experiment.
People might drop
out in the middle,
might decide it's not for
me, actually, I'm done.
And they never actually
figure out what
the point of the experiment was.
You might say, well, who cares?
But you might say, well, who
cares to de-briefing people
in the lab.
If there's a reason for
de-briefing people in the lab
there's probably a good
reason for de-briefing people
on Mechanical Turk.
If they drop out
before their de-brief,
that's kind of a problem.
I don't have a good
solution for it.
It's something to keep in mind.
There's also the
problem that you
should keep in mind
and report, probably,
if it's a problem, the amount
of people who have dropped out
in the middle because
otherwise it can lead
to all sorts of small effects.
Like if your task is really
hard, and a lot of people
drop out, you had
like a 90% dropout
and then you say, oh, people
are brilliant at my task
because the 10% who actually
stuck through with it
are the sort of crazy people
who are willing to do it.
That's actually
really, really skewed.
So keep in mind the
dropout should be low.
It should be like a few
percent or something like that.
The flip side, by the way,
of the no de-briefing problem
is a coercion problem.
So when you bring people into
the lab and you say, you know,
do the study.
You can stop at any time.
No problem at all let me shut
the door and wait over here.
There's sort of a slight
feeling of coercion,
even if the study
is not something
they really are enjoying doing.
They'll still do it because
they feel pressured to.
That problem doesn't
exist, at least
on Amazon Mechanical Turk.
I mean, they're
in it for the pay
and there's some
cost and all that.
But if they really
don't want to do it,
if it offends them in
some way, they'll stop.
So that's actually a bonus.
Some general tips.
Let's see.
And I think I'll
have two more slides
and then we'll wrap it up.
Some general tips.
In general, when you're thinking
about your task, the lower
level it is, the
closer level it is
to-- think about
the Stroop task.
OK, let's put the Stroop task
in one case and the question
I actually asked
you in another case.
The Stroop task is low
level, hard to beat,
even if you've seen
it a million times,
you will still find that effect.
If your task is like that, you
should expect to replicate it.
If it's much more higher
level, the sort of thing that
relies on them not
having seen that before,
it's harder to replicate.
You want to make sure
that people who see it
have not seen it before.
If it's high level and relies
on some sort of zeitgeist,
like what people think about AI
right now, in two years you'll
find a different result.
Don't expect the thing
that I put online
today to replicate
in some sense in two years.
Have participants give comments.
At the end of your
survey, once they're
done, before the de-briefing,
collect some demographics
and leave them something
optional to just say,
what did you think
of this study?
Do you have any comments?
Or anything like that.
Most of the time you
won't get any comments.
After that, the
most likely thing
is they'll say, fun study.
Thanks, if you've
done it correctly.
Interesting, stuff like that.
Some studies we've done have
been crazy and they're very,
you know, they really like it.
And it's nice to
get good feedback.
Or they'll tell
you something like,
that was really interesting,
could you tell me a bit more.
Here's my email address.
Or this button that
didn't work for me.
Or I was actually a bit bothered
by the fact that you said
that you would kill the robot.
Things like that.
Or you ask them things like--
give them comments like, why.
You don't put that necessarily
in your experiment.
But you tell them,
like, you know, do this.
Do that.
Make a decision.
Why?
Like the trolley problem.
OK, it's the sort
of thing that's
not likely to be
published immediately,
but it's definitely
the sort of thing
that will help
you think of where
to take your experiment next.
It's very, very
important to communicate.
And what I mean by that is give
them an email at the beginning
to reach you in some
way, say like, you
know, in the consent statement.
You're doing this experiment.
You're doing it for x.
Here's a way to reach
x if you want to.
AUDIENCE: Do you give
them your actual email?
TOMER ULLMAN: You can set up
a bogus email and the sense
of, like, tomer@mechanicalturk.
I personally give
them my email at MIT.
I do.
And make sure that you
respond to their concerns.
And they will write to you,
especially if something
goes technically wrong.
They'll say, like, you know,
the screen didn't load for me.
I forgot to paste in the
code that you wanted,
things like that.
Or this didn't work quite well.
Write back to them.
Explain what happened.
If they want to know
what the study is about,
you should explain to them
what this study is about.
You should do that
for two reasons.
It feels silly to mention this.
I'm sure you're all, you
know, you've figured it out
by yourselves.
But I'll mention it
anyway, just on the chance
that there's one person
that says, oh yeah,
that's a good reason.
For two reasons, one is that
they'll like you a lot more.
OK, these people, they
go to their own forums.
There's a lot of
Mechanical Turk forums.
There's hundreds of them.
And they tell each other
what things they should do.
They do a good job of
policing each other.
They're like, they try never
to post answers to things,
or like, oh you can do this
by answering this question.
No.
It's like, they don't tolerate
that because they know
that we don't tolerate that.
You want them to like
you in that sense.
You want to get good
reviews on these things.
And one way to garner good
favor is to communicate.
The other reason is because
it's just a good idea.
These are people in the public.
You wouldn't think
about not answering
a question of someone
who came into the lab
and asked you something.
Keep in mind, there's a real
people behind the screen.
Make sure that you treat
them as real people.
I don't mean-- I sound like
I'm berating you or something,
like that you guys have not been
communicating and it's awful.
No.
That's not the point.
I'm sure you all mean
to do that I'm just
trying to emphasize it.
Like I said before,
don't reject unless it's
an extreme situation.
Also, decide ahead of time
how you're going to reject.
Decide ahead of time
on a catch question,
something I'll get
to in a second.
And say, I'm going to reject
people if they do this
and stick to it.
Because otherwise, if you
don't do that, then when
it comes time to actually try
to write a paper you'll say,
well, I think I'll try throwing
out all the people that did it
in under 20 seconds because I
don't think they were paying
attention that much.
Maybe 30 seconds.
Yeah, this test should
really take 40 seconds.
You got the point.
Decide ahead of time on
the rejection criteria.
Have good catch questions.
This is good both for, you
know, knowing who to reject
and making sure that
they're paying attention.
Catch questions are
the sort of thing
that you would put in
the middle of your survey
or at the end of survey, or at
the start of the survey, just
to make sure that they
are paying attention.
Ideally it would be also
that they have actually
read the instructions
and know what
they're supposed to be doing.
So sometimes even if
they're paying attention,
they didn't get the instructions
or something like that.
There's a bunch of different
ways of doing this.
One way of doing
it, you know, I'm
sure you guys can come up
with your own ways I'm just
giving you some examples of
the stuff that people I know
have done.
Toby, for example,
that you've seen
doing some counterfactual
stuff maybe,
he just gives people a
screen with the instructions
and asks them some questions.
And until they get
the question right,
they don't move onto
the next screen.
So he doesn't reject them later.
He just says, in order to
pass to the next screen,
you have to answer this
question correctly.
And he has some way
of checking that.
That's been really good.
Like once he implemented
that, the data is
much, much better and cleaner.
Here's the sort
of catch questions
you don't necessarily
want to do.
They're very popular.
You don't necessarily
want to do them.
They're things like, have you
ever had a fatal heart attack.
And the answer
is, of course, no.
Have you ever eaten
a sandwich on Mars.
It's the sort of
thing that like you're
trying to catch people that are
going through it very quickly
and are just marking
things randomly.
One of the reasons you
don't want to do that
is because even if they're
answering randomly yes or no,
you'll still miss 50% who
just got it right by error.
The other reason is
the standard stuff.
I mean, I'm sure you guys
could come up with something.
But there's a lot of
examples out there.
The two examples
I just gave you,
the Martian, the
fatal heart attack,
this is stuff that gets used
over and over and over again.
And they sort of just know it.
One of them said
like, any time I
see the person I
told you before was
like juggling kids and trying
to answer at the same time.
He says, oh yeah, whenever
I see the word vacuum,
I know it's time for
an attention check
because it's going to
be like, have you ever
eaten a sandwich in a vacuum
or like something like that.
But whenever I see vacuum, it's
obviously an attention check.
You don't want to do that.
Ideally, you want
to have something
that relates to the task.
So in one of our
examples, we were
doing some sort of Turing task.
And we just wanted
to say, like, here,
complete the following sentence.
You were playing
the game against a--
and then it's an open text box.
OK, some of these people
have like automatic robots
that fill it in.
So they'll do
something like, thanks.
Or yes.
Or something like that.
Then they just hope
that yes will match.
But here the correct
answer was robot.
You were playing the
game against a robot,
or against a human, or
something like that.
Did people get that example?
OK.
So ideally, the
good catch question
is an open field,
something that's
not just you can click
and get right by mistake
and relates something
to the instructions
that you were giving.
This is not a tip.
This is something you should do.
Again, it's trivial.
You'll have to do it if
you're thinking of running it
in your own university
and your university
has never done
Mechanical Turk before,
get IRB approval specifically
for Mechanical Turk.
So just make sure
you get IRB approval.
Make sure you get
informed consent
at the beginning of your
study, say like, we're
going to be doing this.
If it's OK click on this
button that says, I agree.
Usually the IRB will force
you to do that anyway.
And as I said, ethical pay, I
just keep going back to that.
OK, there's various helpful
tools for running experiments.
If any of you are interested
in this, reading more about it,
much more in depth
how to actually run
an experiment and
things like that,
come talk to me afterwards.
Or look at Todd
Gureckis's website.
Other websites that
you should check out.
These are the forums
you should probably
know about, TurkerNation,
mTurkGrind, and TurkOpticon.
These are useful both to get
a sense of how your task is
doing, are people sort
of responding to it
saying something about it.
It's also a good place
to publicize your study.
If I need 300 participants
within two hours,
I can put it on Turk and
hope the pay is enough.
Or I can put it on mTurkGrind.
People there have
liked our tasks before
and they'll give you
a thumbs up and you'll
get 200 people within an
hour just because they
know about you and they know
that you're an OK person,
and you communicate.
So it's a good practice
to get a user name
on one of these things,
or both of them,
when you run an
actual experiment.
Explain what you're doing.
Put it on there.
Be willing to answer questions.
TurkOpticon is the usual
thing that will then be used--
this is what one of these
forums looks like, by the way.
They're like, you
know, oh it's terrible.
It's Tuesday.
What should we do today?
Here's how much I've done today.
Somebody says, I didn't
see this posted anywhere.
Very interesting to those of
you who want to do 3D printing.
Then there's like the
title of the experiment
and a description of it.
And people can just
click directly from there
to the experiment.
Usually the experiments
that they post on the forums
looks something like this.
They're getting these numbers
off of that last website
that I just mentioned,
TurkOpticon.
So usually when people want to
rate you on Mechanical Turk,
they're not going to complain
to Amazon because Amazon's not
going to do anything about it.
Like I said before,
requesters have a lot of power
and Amazon doesn't bother
to arbitrate, usually.
So one of the ways that they
do have of either rewarding
or punishing you is
to go to TurkOpticon
and give you a rating for
communication, generosity,
fairness, and promptness.
And those numbers will then
be used on most of the forums
when you publish your task.
People can see, like, these guys
have actually cheated people
before, or something like that.
So you can go, once you've
registered, go to TurkOpticon
and you can check out your own
ratings and things like that.
So yeah, in summary, Mechanical
Turk is a wonderful resource.
I hope I haven't scared you
away from it, those of you who
are thinking about doing it.
It amplifies everything.
You can do a lot
more a lot faster.
But it doesn't get
rid of concerns,
it amplifies those concerns.
So things like ethical
concerns and payment concerns,
and things like that, the
sort of same sort of concerns
that you would have in the
lab, those are included there,
and other magnified
100-fold because you're
recruiting a lot more people.